how you doing guys today we have 2009
Honda Pilot and we're going to create
another key let's get
started so the customer have a remote
head key it's broken he put a regular
screw and we're going to create another
aftermarket remote head key I'm going to
use the SEC E9 machine uh high security
and I'm going to put the original one
first and um I'm going to go and choose
the blade h n6 66 with six cuts on each
side and I'm going to hit de code and
we're going to decode the original
[Music]
key I'm going to fast
forward after it's decoded I'm going to
take the key out and I'm going to check
to make sure that all the cuts are make
sense
and in this situation it looks like the
last two digits it's a 32 on the machine
but um it always ends with a one so I'm
going to change I'm going to adjust the
input on the
machine I'm going to put the original
key I'm going to go to the input I'm
going to slide all the way to the right
side and I'm going to change it to a one
and hit
okay now I can cut it I'm going to cut
it uh slower than regular because it's a
very thick key and we're going to start
[Music]
cutting whenever it's ready I'm going to
clean up the metal shavings and we're
going to switch the key to the other
side and we're going to cut it as
[Music]
well
when everything is finished we can clean
up the metal shavings and go to the car
test it out and start the
[Music]
programming I'm going to use the IM 100
or the newer one is one
im508 I'm going to connect it to the OBD
I'm going to put the original Keyon on
position without starting the car I'm
going to go to
immobilizer and I'm going to accept the
terms I'm going to go to the Asian
market I'm going to go to
Honda by the way if you like those
videos don't forget to like And
subscribe so you can see our daily
locksmith videos I really appreciate
it so it's loading all the
information we're going to go to
automatic selection because the ignition
is on on position and we're going to
read the VIN
number we're going to hit okay and we're
going to hit blade key because this is
not a push to
start and we want to make sure that we
have our model and all the information
and hit
yes we're going to go to hot
function it tells us to use the cable
hit okay turn ignition on ignition is
already on on position as you can see
and we're going to hit
[Music]
okay
first of all it's trying to figure it
out what type of system and it tells you
it's Fourth blade key system so it
recognize the system hit okay and it's
going to show you uh add key we don't
want to delete all of them because the
customer have another key at home we're
going to hit start it shows you all the
functions that it's go through all the
processes just hit okay insert a
register key turn ignition on it's
already on hit yes
[Music]
every step it's good if if everything is
good it's going to show
success so it's going to read the amount
of keys in the memory
three turn the ignition off within 15
seconds insert ignition registered key
and turn it
on
all right would you like to learn the
next key I'm going to hit
yes turn the ignition off within 15
seconds and then it tells me to put the
new one and put it on on
[Music]
position programming succeeded would you
like to program next one I'm going to
hit
no turn
off turn on with the same
key turn it off by the way this is the
close closing the programming mode turn
it
[Music]
on do both lights that the light is off
the light is already off I'm going to
hit yes that's the security
light turn
off turn back
[Music]
on and there is four keys in the memory
so if we slide up we're going to see
three but now the remote is still not
working but it should start the
[Music]
car nice and easy in order to program
the remote we're going to take the
original key we don't need the machine
and and we're going to turn it to on
position and we're going to click the
lock button and we're going to turn it
off four times so we're going to open
and close the door we're going to do on
button off on button off on button off
on button off we should hear cycle we're
going to hit one more time on each
remote to register and then we can test
it
lock
unlock
everything worked the way it should guys
don't forget to like And subscribe if
you have any questions let me know in
the comments below I love to answer all
your questions and I really appreciate
you guys watching thank you and we'll
see you in the next
one